I'm Greg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday March 17 2023 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal the White House shifts on oil
drilling and the Border as the
administration grapples with responses
to bank failures and Russia I do have
every confidence in the world that this
is going to be a major topic during the
campaign Trail as we head into 2024. we
speak with Fox News anchor Dana Perino
I'm Dave Anthony
he's confident he'll be proven right
the Doctor Who led the Centers for
Disease Control when covid first hit
believes the Chinese lab League Theory
it's very very very probable that this
great pandemic was caused by science and
an arrogance of Science and I'm Tom
shallou I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
the White House was in
action mode beginning the week with a
bank intervention as Silicon Valley Bank
and Signature Bank failed the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation and the
FED stepped in the president promised
depositors would be made whole and no
tax dollars would be used if the bank is
taken over by FDIC the people running
the bank should not work there anymore
third investors in the banks will not be
protected but Republicans like Idaho
senator Mike crapo add a finance
committee hearing this week focused
treasury secretary Janet Yellen on some
of the potential causes of those Banks
underlying problems their Capital was
being was losing value and they were not
able to access their capital and and I
attribute that to the interest rate
hikes that we are seeing in in the face
of the inflation am I wrong in that
crapo said of her response good then
we're on the same page Yellen insisted
the U.S banking system is sound later in
the week the Pentagon announced that
Russia had forced down one of our uavs a
drone dumping fuel on it in the process
defense secretary Lloyd Austin said we
don't want things to escalate with
Russia but Republican Florida
Congressman Michael Waltz told Fox
anchor Harris Faulkner the broader
agenda here is we pulled our ships out
we pulled our manned aircraft out now we
have unmanned aircraft in international
waters and the Russians want to force
them out too and the response can't be
we do nothing in recent days though some
members of the president's own party are
pushing back on what appear to be shifts
in the president's thinking on other
matters the administration approved the
massive Willow project in Alaska
allowing Conoco Phillips to move forward
with an oil drilling Venture the
administration's also implemented new
rules at the border including requiring
those who apply for Asylum to First
apply for asylum in a country they
passed through on their way here that
was a similar rule implemented during
the Trump Administration I think there's
a few things that are happening one is
reality is starting to bite Dana Perino
is a co-anchor of America's Newsroom and
host of the everything will be okay
podcast so the fact that there are
policies that they've had for the first
two years are not yielding any good
results on the border on crime and on
energy especially on inflation even
though they could point to it coming
down a little bit it is still really
hurting people where it counts so part
of it is reality the second thing that
happened is that they saw that in
particular on crime when Lori Lightfoot
failed to win re-election in Chicago as
the mayor for the first time in 40 years
the first Chicago mayor not to win
re-election and the issue was crime that
was a real wake-up call and also because
you have somebody like mayor Eric Adams
where the two things come together he's
got a crime problem when it comes to
Progressive prosecution and not having
enough police that's a direct result of
the defund the police movement and then
you also have the situation where the
mayor of New York is saying to the
federal government I need help in order
to deal with the migrant crisis which is
not just a border issue this is here in
New York they're spending four and a
half million dollars every single day
in order to help migrants and there's no
shortage of the lines that are
continuing to come through
and then you have the actual border
problems I think that the Democrats are
realizing that they do have some
significant political challenges when it
comes to keeping Latino votes even
though they still win the majority of
them it's not as large a margin as they
had before so partly it's reality and
partly it's also politics because the
Administration has been very far left
and Progressive even though Joe Biden
said he was the moderate guy and he was
the one who could bring everyone
together that's not how we govern in the
first two years and they'll be able to
say look at all the things we got done
but I think a lot of those
accomplishments are now vulnerabilities
so then you look at the fact that he
wants to run for re-election and I
predicted that he would approve the
willow project because it was very easy
for him to do why would I say that it's
an important project but it doesn't
erase the fact that for the first two
years of the administration they were
decimating
domestic energy production wherever they
possibly could on the same day that he
approved the willow project he took 13
million of the 20 million Acres that are
available for energy exploration in
Alaska off the table if you ask the
Alaska Governor if he's happy about the
willow project well sure but he said at
the cost of losing out on everything
else not great and you can't forget the
Keystone Pipeline workers who are still
waiting for the jobs that John Kerry
said that they'd be able to get in the
green energy economy so he's moved a
tiny bit from the far left position to
the more Centrist position but I don't
know if that's going to be enough let's
talk about what happened this week
Russian pilots in International Space
right crashed into and took down one of
our drones secretary Austin was asked if
this was an act of War he said we take
any potential for escalation seriously
and keeping lines of communication open
helps prevent miscalculations going
forward we heard the open lines of
communication being important after the
Chinese spy balloon incident as far as
messaging goes
it sounds like an Administration trying
to sort of downplay these incidents
whether from China from Russia and not
escalate but Republicans are demanding a
stronger response is a stronger response
warranted or are we getting an
Administration that thinks it's trying
to walk a fine line here I think the
administration for what we can see and
what they have told us has struck it
just about right because Putin would
like to see an escalation we don't want
to see an escalation Putin wants it to
look like there's an escalation so that
he can tell the world that this is a
fight between Russia and the United
States in Ukraine and we should be very
cautious about being dragged into that
debate while the ukrainians also might
want to stir the pot and try to get us
there I think we need to be aware that
Putin wants to give the appearance that
things are escalating and that things
may quickly serve out of control why
because it plays to Biden's natural
fears of starting World War III it also
gives Comfort to the Germans and other
stragglers that we should back off
because Putin may go crazy because Putin
wants to exploit the fears of those
giving Ukraine piecemeal half measures
and also we cannot let Russians
establish new rules of engagement that
aircraft and international waters are
fair game we have to push back hard and
the administration and did the right
thing in declassifying the video so that
everybody could see the world now knows
that Russia was absolutely the aggressor
in that incident I briefly want your
thoughts on these bank failures we've
been seeing this week Idaho Republican
senator Mike krapo said during a hearing
with treasury secretary Yellen he
criticized the administration's spending
and he and other Republicans point out
what some analysts have been pointing
out that the FED raised rates as quickly
as they did in response to inflation
this impacted bond prices that
contributes to Banks failing is this a
narrative Republicans successfully push
and does this Administration needed a
different or stronger response to
Republicans points about Bank regulation
I think these are all very good
questions that I don't know the answer
to yet but I'm not sure anybody does yet
and that's probably partly because we're
still in the middle of it all I think
that the administration trying to
suggest that their actions were not a
bailout will not sit well politically
with a lot of people across the country
both on the left and the right and
there's also this call from Elizabeth
Warren that we should do even more from
a regulatory standpoint I think you're
going to have a lot of moderate
Democrats and certainly any Democrat
that has this large rural population in
their constituency they're not going to
want that you don't do we really want to
go to a situation where we have just
four big nationalized Banks which is
where we do this that's socialism we we
don't want that as a country
and then when it comes to the fed you
know they needed to increase rates so
that we could try to get a handle on
inflation
and of course we know how inflation got
caused if you look back to the previous
segment of what we just talked about so
I'm not exactly sure how it ends in
terms of a substance standpoint but I do
have every confidence in the world that
this is going to be a major topic during
the campaign Trail as we head into 2024.
you have season three of your podcast
beginning here based on your book
everything will be okay which we all
love when we actually hear you say those
words
um we know it's also geared toward
helping young women navigate life really
I I wanted your brief thoughts I mean we
are seeing these record statistics out
about teenage girls really struggling
with mental health I I know you you can
speak to that I mean are we
are we are we focusing on parents
schools social media all of it as you
dive into that kind of topic I do
believe everything will be okay but that
as I write in my book is not just
something you take for granted that's
something you actually have to work for
it's not a passive exercise and there
are a lot of problems in our country
right now there's just so many and the
health of our young people is one of
them Jillian Turner has done an amazing
job on Fox News all week highlighting
the different aspects of mental health
and teen girls and the real struggles
that they have but don't forget boys
also have these problems too and social
media
combined with covid combined with this
new Fentanyl push where one pill can
kill I think parents are extremely on
edge they're looking at the fact that
the jobs that they thought their kids
might be able to get that would have
really good futures for them might not
exist because of artificial intelligence
and you have kids that walk around with
so much anxiety that they think the
world's about to end
so as adults we have a responsibility to
do something about that on the podcast
I've talked to people dealing with the
foster care system and trying to help
young people who are at age 18 age out
of the system and then 20 000 of them
age out every year half of them will
become homeless
wow Dr Charles Payne about the
importance of inner city education and
how all across America We are failing
these children which means that they
will likely fail as adults unless given
the opportunity to catch up
and I also am going to talk to Benjamin
Hall
who is our colleague who was
severely wounded in Ukraine as he was
reporting on the war and lost two of his
good colleagues and our our colleagues
as well and
if you ever wondered if you could truly
believe that everything is going to be
okay
you just have to meet Benjamin Hall and
read his book saved a war reporter's
mission to make it home
Because he believes everything is going
to be okay
and if that's the case then surely we
can believe it too we'll we'll end it on
that positive note Dana Perino co-anchor
of America's Newsroom and host of the
everything will be okay podcast thank
you so much for joining us I was honored
thank you
[Music]
this is Tom shallou with your Fox News
commentary coming up
will we ever know definitively where
kovid came from
the U.S is still investigating and this
is rare lawmakers from both parties
unanimously agreed in the House and
Senate to declassify U.S intelligence on
kovid's Origins Republican senator Josh
Hawley tells Fox listen the American
people it's past time let's show them
what the government has let everybody
see for themselves let everybody read it
last week the now GOP LED house
committee investigating the pandemic
held a hearing on kovid's Origins in
China and the former head of the CDC
when the virus first hit us in early
2020 testified based on my initial
analysis of the data I came to believe
and I still believe today that it
indicates that covid-19 more likely was
the result of an accidental lab leak
than a result of a natural spillover
event Dr Robert Redfield joins the FBI
and energy Department assessing a
Chinese lab leak theory is likely
another member of the coronavirus task
force the Trump White House set up then
was not at the hearing Dr Anthony fauci
was discussed though as Republicans
including Congressman Jim Jordan focused
on his emails from that time Dr fauci
gets an email from Dr Christian Anderson
which says virus looks engineered virus
not consistent with evolutionary theory
the next day he gets another email from
Dr Gary now these are doctors he's
handed out our tax dollars to over the
years Dr Gary's email says I don't know
how this happens in nature it would be
easy to do in a lab that same day
February 1st 2020. so again right at the
start that same day Dr fauci organizes a
conference call him and Dr Collins get
on there with Dr Gary Dr Anderson all
these other virologists they get on
there and three days later everybody
changes their story but Dr fauci told
Fox after the hearing I have always kept
a completely the open mind that it could
be one or the other but he certainly did
Lean toward the theory as scientists
studied it the virus naturally skipped
from bat to animal to human it looked
much more likely that was a lot doubt it
was a natural occurrence from an animal
Reservoir and Dr fauci as we'll get into
later took issue with an allegation that
he left the CDC director out of
conversations on discrediting that lab
leak Theory as disinformation but Dr
Redfield says it's out of their hands
now I think we're Beyond now where
science is going to answer the question
I think the question is going to be
answered by the intelligence Community
before he was CDC director Dr Robert
Redfield was chief of retroviral
research at the Walter Reed Army
Institute of research we can't get the
scientific information we need now and
secondly so much time has passed that a
lot of the scientific evidence that we
want now is blurred but the intelligence
is still there I'm still of the view
that there'll be several defectors that
will come forward and really make it
very clear what really did happen this
lab that everyone's focused on in Wuhan
where the outbreak started
it studies coronaviruses correct so it
would make sense that covid would be
born out of some sort of a leak listen
that laboratory studies coronavirus is
that laboratory published in 2014 that
it accomplished one of its major goals
which was to teach coronaviruses to
infect human tissue right and they
published that in a scientific journal
and they thanked the NIH for the help of
the financial support for doing those
studies and they were able to make the
virus now that could not bind the human
tissue learn how to bind through what we
call the H2 receptor and so they
accomplished that basically six years
before the pandemic okay now help me
understand this because you're a
virologist you've been studying this for
for decades we listening to you are not
so this is something is this what people
have debated as gain of function
research yeah the the laboratory was
involved in gain of function research
and focus particularly on how to get
these bad viruses to change their
species tropism so they could now infect
humans
and all that means is they put a
cleavage piece in so the the virus would
cleave and change the orientation of The
Binding site so this binding site which
naturally doesn't bind to human tissue
now with this shearing cleavage site
aggressively bound to human tissue all
right and we I believe that change
happened in the laboratory through what
you call we call gain a functional
research now when you were at the
hearing and you spoke about how you were
excluded from a call that was uh
discussing the origins of covet in the
early days of all this now that has
gotten some pushback you've probably
seen you've probably heard but Dr fauci
he spoke to Fox's Neil Cavuto last week
and this is what he had to say I want
you to hear Dr fauci he is totally and
unequivocally incorrect In what he's
saying that I excluded him I had nothing
to do with who would be on that call
that call all was organized by a group
of evolutionary virologists in order to
discuss the possibility that this might
actually be a virus that was actually
engineered so I didn't put anybody on
the list of that call nor did I take
anybody else and he says half the people
on the call felt it might have been from
a lab what's your response to his
response to your testimony well I think
he's incorrect you know uh Tony it was
totally within Tony's power to make sure
my voice was able to be part of that
call and I didn't know that the call had
occurred actually until the Freedom of
Information Act came out and showed that
they had these colds I was quite
disappointed that he and his colleagues
didn't give me the opportunity to fully
participate in those discussions I mean
I was a CDC director I was the
individual that asked for this
aggressive scientific evaluation so I
don't know who sent the invitations out
I know I didn't get one I know I didn't
get participate I know he didn't discuss
this and I know several days after that
call everybody on that call that he says
thought like me somehow flipped their
position and that they they all agreed
to a single narrative that it came from
nature I'm not going to say who I spoke
to that was on that call but I did talk
to people after I found out about it
after the Freedom of Information and
tried to figure out why I wasn't
included and I was told that I wasn't
included because it was decided there
needed to be a single narrative a single
decision that we all signed up and
agreed to and there was a consensus that
I wouldn't agree to that there but I was
not engaged and I think he's
disingenuous in his pushback okay now
there was a lot of talkers and the the
the natural occurrence from bat or
animal to human that there was this
Market in Wuhan where they sell wild
animal meat and supposedly the concept
being that the bat had maybe bitten one
of these wild animals and then people
consumed that and therefore that's how
there's the intermediary
why is that theory implausible to you
so when you looked at SARS from the
original outbreak in 2003 we had less
than a thousand cases in the world right
we have millions of cases of coven same
with
um MERS so these coronaviruses when they
jump species
they don't immediately know how to
efficiently transmit in humans but when
this virus came into humans it literally
was probably the second most infectious
virus we have in humans behind measles
so it's just not natural it's not
plausible it's not how these viruses
jump species you can't say every virus
is the same but coronaviruses don't do
this the second problem I have with it
and this is where people are being
disingenuous and that's probably a
polite word all right they say it came
from the wet Market in the end of
December
the fact is we now know for certain that
this virus epidemic movement probably
started between August and October had
nothing to do with the wet part okay it
happened months before the wetmark so if
those scientists who published the
Proctor origin were maintaining their
scientific Integrity the first thing
they should do now is retract that paper
but we do know in September and it's
Declassified that laboratory did three
things in September mid-september it
erased all the sequences of the batch
coronaviruses that they ever sequenced
it's highly irregular scientists usually
don't erase their work
and I think it's important because they
didn't want to be able to allow people
to trace the sequence differences
particularly when it came to the fear
and cleavage side Etc okay
the second thing they did is they put
that lab in charge the lab was no longer
was removed the civilian in charge of
the lab was removed and they put the
Chinese military Church
in September which again and the third
you would say is irregular highly
irregular right and the third thing they
did which I think is the key
is they put a contract in to redo the
ventilation system of a lab all of that
before December of 2019. all all in
September and we have you know and again
it's been Declassified to some degree
some of it there's clear evidence that
lab workers and people Wuhan were
beginning to get a non-flue-like
respiratory illness in between August
and October
uh and then it started spreading now
remember and I was very in close contact
with my counterpart George gal had a CDC
in China uh George you know assured me
initially that there was no human to
human transmission I challenged him
because of the first 27 cases three of
them there were three clusters in
families and I said George I'm not
convinced you're right these are three
clusters in the same family it sounds
like it might have gone from person to
person he said he had high degree of
confidence it didn't well he was wrong
and the second thing he said
um that there's and this is the problem
calling it SARS like he said there was
no asymptomatic illness turns out from
for covid the most common transmission
is asymptomatic
um you know normally I don't like to you
know get speak out and be and targeted
but it's very important we get the
origin because the origin of this virus
and I've said it's very very very
probable that this great pandemic was
caused by science and an arrogance of
science that they didn't see the
downside of their gain of function
research I've asked for a moratorium on
gain of function research and I think
that's why we get into origin so
important because I'm not sure society's
ready for that I wish China had been
more transparent post a pandemic but
it's not China's problem it happened to
be done in a Chinese lab but it was
funded by NIH it was funded by the state
department it was funded by usaid and it
was defunded by the United States
defense department but China Let It Go
and spread around the world so yeah
their response afterwards was
problematic I'll agree with that but
don't give the American Scientific
Community a free pass they funded it
right and don't give the European
scientific community and the scientific
Union large the free pass because in
2011 and 2012 they went on an aggressive
campaign to support gain a function
research well Dr fauci has said over and
over again that that's not true do you
think he's lying I was lying about what
well he has gone back and forth with
Senator Rand Paul about whether the U.S
uh was backing and funding gain of
function research on coven and and he is
he's said that that's not true do you
yeah yeah no his his comments are highly
misleading and not truthful now whether
he understands that or not Tony you know
is playing with words because what he'll
tell you is he petitions he got a group
of independent scientists to come up in
the National Academy and others and they
redefine to gain a functional research
and they Define it in a way that he
believes excludes the work that was done
in the lab but this was definitely
getting a function research he's parsing
words it's come back to the Clinton well
what's the meaning of is this is gain of
function research and that most people
of good will
I can see that
Dr Robert Redfield former director of
The Centers for Disease Control under
President Trump at the time when the
pandemic started thank you so much for
joining us yeah thanks
[Music]
news with Tanya J powers
this week's good news comes from New
Jersey where a former Rutgers football
star has launched a company that pairs
bourbon with benefits benefits for
charity that is Eric Legrand sustained a
spinal cord injury during a game in
October of 2010 which left him paralyzed
from the neck down he overcame an
initially Grim prognosis and has been
giving back ever since through his team
Legrand which was launched in September
of 2013 as a fundraising arm for the
Christopher and Dana Reeve Foundation
since then team Legrand has raised well
over 2 million dollars for the reef
Foundation he created his own clothing
brand launched his own coffee company in
2012 and now Eric has co-founded his own
whiskey brand it's called Eric Legrand
Kentucky Straight Bourbon whiskey and
will benefit the reef Foundation as well
in a statement Eric said his recovery
journey is a lot like making a great
bourbon in that both take Precision
patience and Trust in the process Eric's
work with the refund station's neuro
recovery network isn't just as a
supporter he was also a participant
taking part in a rigorous rehabilitation
program that included re-teaching his
body how to walk and improving his
quality of life
thanks to that therapy he has regained
movement in his shoulders and has made
improvements to his overall health you
can find out more about Eric his coffee
whiskey and podcast at Eric
legrand52.com Tanya J Powers Fox News
[Music]
is the fox True Crime podcast bringing
you closer to the story than you ever
thought possible subscribe at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts these are the stories
that keep you up at night subscribe to
this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com it's
time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind when I was a kid St
Patrick's Day was one of the biggest
holidays of the year I remember one day
when I was in elementary school I came
running downstairs into the kitchen in
my green outfit with my paper Erin go
bra hat on my head and my mother shouted
to me what are you doing
you're supposed to be in school and I
said mom don't you know it's St
Patrick's Day and she said you still
have to go to school on St Patrick's Day
I couldn't believe it
what the biggest day of the year and I'm
gonna sit in a classroom
I used to love the annual St Patrick's
Day Parade in my hometown of Norwood
Massachusetts and then when I was older
I went into the big one in Boston as an
adult I've seen many of the parades here
in New York City and this year I'm going
down to Savannah reporting for Fox and
Friends Savannah has the third biggest
St Patrick's Day Parade after New York
and Boston
we're gonna have a great time but really
I love the small town events last year I
went to St Patrick's Day in my
neighboring town of Tuckahoe in
Westchester County where I live they
have a great parade it reminded me of
those small town parades I attended when
I was a kid
however you celebrate I hope you have a
great St Patrick's Day but kids you
still gotta go to school I'm Tom shallow
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hey it's Will Kane co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend join me as I share my
thoughts on a wide range of topics from
Sports and pop culture to politics and
business so will Kane podcast subscribe
and listen now at foxnewspodcasts.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes